for much of the southern united states
it was a once in a generation winter
storm
heavy snowfall and icy roads conjured up
disastrous driving conditions
across at least 20 states several of
them declaring states of emergency
in texas record low temperatures way
below freezing
brought the electricity grid to its
knees at one point more than two million
customers there lost
power many caught up in intentional
outages
designed to ease the strain on the
system
we have experienced probably five or six
rolling blackouts
at about 45 minutes each i know that
there are some neighborhoods around here
that have been
without power since about 4am even
southern texas
more accustomed to hurricanes got a rare
sight
of snow this was the scene in bel air
a suburb of houston and in san antonio
home to the alamo
a famous historical site here's what it
looked like
there you know we got snow in front of
the alamo i
don't live too far but man you never
think you see the day until you got snow
coming down like this
according to the national weather
service at least 150 million americans
are in the storm's path an unusually
wide band of frigid air
creeping slowly across the country other
states bearing the brunt of it have been
oklahoma
where it's caused near whiteout
conditions on the roads
and north carolina where freezing rain
felled trees
along highways further north in chicago
they're more used to this kind of
weather at this time of the year
but even here they're bracing for more
than 30 centimeters of snow
by the time the storm passes through
the new york city region has already
seen its highest
snowfall totals in years but the storm
that's sweeping through the rest of the
country is now
barreling north and about to hit here
leaving tens of millions of other
americans in the northeast of the
country bracing for the next one
that also could include sleet and hail
gabriel zondo al jazeera weehawken new
jersey